[music playing]
OFFICER HERNANDEZ: We're
going to have to take
this back to the office.
Yeah.
That box will not be going
to its final destination.
I appreciate you
carrying the heavy stuff.
OFFICER HERNANDEZ: So
when it comes to firearms
in particular, we have to
exert an extraordinary amount
of caution dealing
with firearms,
because we do not know if
they are loaded or not.
So as a rule of thumb,
we always treat all
firearms as if they're loaded.
So we have a specific procedure
that we use in order to clear
the weapon to make
sure that there
isn't any incidental
discharges, any accidents,
nothing of the sort.
At least they're not loaded.
A couple of pistols.
It's a 30 round max.
The glock.
OFFICER HERNANDEZ: A lot
of accessories, grips--
Appears to be a mini AK-47.
This is a good seizure,
considering all the violence is
going on in Trinidad right now.
It's always good to take
guns off the street.
We don't really know to
whom it was going to.
A lot of times they used
fake names or aliases,
but this is a good catch.
It's most definitely
a good seizure.
These were meant to cause
bodily harm and injury
towards someone, whether
it be an innocent person
or another narco.
So the effort that we put
out there all together--
it's worth it when you come
across something like this.
We definitely save lives.
[music playing]